[Music]
if you look at the earlier registered
passengers on board
Virgin Galactic for example they have
astronauts in their 80s that are raring
to go so I see great opportunities for
for older astronauts to get onboard
Virgin Galactic and Blue Origin and
SpaceX in the near future certainly one
of the greatest honors of my life was
getting a chance to fly in space with my
boyhood hero Senator John Glenn he you
know he's up on the the pinnacle of
Heroes as a kid he was the very first
door 'but the earth as an american back
in 1962 you know back when rockets
didn't necessarily always behave there
were a lot of failures in fact that the
two launches right before john's flight
as I recall blew up and he was on number
three so there were definitely brave men
back in those early days and so it was
an incredible thrill to welcome him back
to the astronaut ranks and to fly with
him on SGS 95 he came back at age 77 the
oldest astronaut ever and we were
basically studying his adaptation to
space and riad apt a shinned Earth's one
gravity you know going up into space is
sort of like an accelerated aging
process when even a younger astronaut
goes into space we have weakening of our
muscles and bones and our heart because
it doesn't have to pump against gravity
we are resisting the force of gravity to
move ourselves around so it's it's like
your your body is going on holiday and
and so it's actually a great laboratory
for developing countermeasures to the
aging process that was the real reason
we wanted to to bring John on board is
to compare and contrast and older
astronauts experiences with with a
younger astronaut population and he did
an amazing job he was in phenomenal
shape and just a wonderful human being
to be around we learned a lot by having
him on board with us one of the things
that was really striking is just how
well an older person does adapt to space
he was able to perform right lockstep
with every other crew member on board
contributed in every facet of the
mission he was actually a subject in ten
different life sciences
parents I had to draw gallons and
gallons of his blood which he didn't
care for very much but but he helped us
understand those differences and and one
of the things that he did struggle with
a little bit coming back to Earth's one
gravity he had issues with getting his
balance back the neurovestibular system
was was a little slow to recover not
dissimilar to some of our longer
duration astronauts when they come back
from their missions to the ISS but
certainly nothing that was a showstopper
it was like a dream come true to have
someone that I had revered as a kid
become not just a crew mate but a close
friend and you know I as I talk about it
all the time so one of the high points
of my career for sure
[Music]